[Music]
the most powerful force to that defines
religion is society it's very important
to understand that religion is an ever
malleable thing it there is no such
thing as Christianity it doesn't exist
there are Christianity's and the way
that one defines the gospel the way that
one understands Jesus as either the Son
of God or the Messiah or as a you know a
great teacher to to to emulate the way
that one place is sort of the the
Christology or even the Credo formula of
Catholicism has everything to do with
where one lives if you are a Catholic
living in suburban Denver with your
two-and-a-half kids in your car in your
house your Jesus is probably a white
blond-haired blue-eyed peacenik who
turns the other cheek if you're a
Catholic living in the hills of
Guatemala you're Jesus
besides being Mexican is a fighter a
liberator one who stands up to the
oppressor and indeed who takes up arms
against oppression it's the same Jesus
it's the same Catholicism but the
understanding is radically different
depending on where you live the same of
course is true of Islam if you're a
Muslim living in Detroit then your idea
of Islam is a religion of peace and
submission and and pluralism if you're a
Muslim living on a garbage heap on Gaza
then your version of Islam is as a
religion of social justice so everywhere
that you go
you will see different expressions
different manifestations of what can be
called the same religion the same faith
I think that we need to understand that
because in a way too often we look at
the differences between religious
communities as being defined as
differences in religion and frankly it's
more often differences of community than
it is of religion religion is an
ever-evolving process if a religion
stops evolving it dies and there are
thousands and thousands of examples of
dead religions in the world that we can
talk about that simply went away because
they were not able to adapt to the
constant changes of human civilization
in human societies the reason we talk
about the great religions Islam
Christianity Judaism Hinduism Buddhism
these five massive world religions that
have been around for thousands of years
and that have billions of worldwide
followers what makes them great is
because they're constantly adapting
they're constantly evolving that's why
they continue to exist the moment you
stop adapting the moment you stop
evolving to whatever social political
economic or cultural landscape that the
religion finds itself in the mats the
moment in which it goes away we're
talking about Islam particularly as it's
experienced in the Middle East I think
you can't talk about the the rise of the
Islamic state or the rise of jihadism or
any of the various political or economic
or religious conflicts that are taking
place in that region without first
starting with colonialism the
colonialist experience which you know
came to an end only about half a century
ago we tend to forget that was a
profound experience for the world's
Muslims you're talking about an era in
which 90% of the world's Muslim
population lived under direct colonial
control it had an enormous influence on
the development of the modern
Muslim consciousness and the way that it
sort of allowed Muslims to define
themselves as opposed to an other in
this case a rabidly westernizing and
aggressively Christianizing and and
total dominating force a force that
dominated the social economic political
and religious landscape of the Middle
East had I think an enormous influence
on the way that Muslims began to see
themselves visa vie the rest of the
world and with the end of the
colonialist experience with the
decolonization period that began around
the second world war and accelerated
immediately after that and this
geopolitical fragmentation that was left
behind in which Muslim populations who
had hitherto thought of themselves as
members of a worldwide community of
faith were now suddenly forced to think
of themselves as citizens of
nation-states nation-states that in most
cases were created through arbitrary
borders and totally fabricated
nationalities with the sole purpose of
making these parcels of land more easily
divisible and and passed and pass along
amongst the the colonialist whether they
be French or Dutch or English or
Portuguese or Spanish the idea that now
you had to sort of define yourself in
this in this incredibly unfamiliar way I
think really rattled a lot of Muslim
civilizations some of them were able to
do so without much trouble but many
Muslim states particularly in the Arab
world I think really are to this day
having a very difficult time trying to
define what exactly it even means to be
a Muslim state does it mean that you
have to have Muslim governance does it
mean that you have to be ruled by
Islamic law does it just simply mean
that you're a majority Muslim
state what what is it how does one
define oneself and I think that
particularly in the language that we use
when we talk about the countries in that
region as Muslim states it doesn't help
because frankly I can't imagine what
Morocco has in common with Saudi Arabia
or what Saudi Arabia has in common with
Turkey over turkey has in common with
Indonesia absolutely nothing not
language not culture not ethnicity not
customs not religion and yet we refer to
all of them as Islamic states so I think
it's not just Muslims themselves that
are having a hard time defining
post-colonial middle-east and what that
means I think the rest of the world is
having just as a difficult time it's
figuring it out
[Music]